try um I remember that first time when I
know about livejournal I'd rather was
among those who said Oh horrible thing
it's very bad sign of you x it's
absolutely human less everything is
disgusting this possibility too I don't
know to make these spiritual striptease
and Sons on in half a year I got my arm
bone journal and I think that it's very
not so awful thing first of all it gives
some people possibility I think
possibility not to be alone it's maybe
strange maybe weird substitution of old
our friendship or old relations between
people but tumbly it is it goes like
this just because times change without
the hand if to talk about writers
probably many are some of others voids
and writers they cannot wait for the
moment when they pumps will be published
in so-called thick magazines thick thick
thick magazines this number of literary
literature magazines of literature which
are accepted as I don't know those who
are published in those magazines they
are part of the literature establishment
of in Russia because sometimes it
takes to wait for the publication one or
two months maybe three are and the other
cases those Poyet's those authors will
never published in those megan's because
now i don't know editor's think could
think that the spoiled point their work
it does not convenient for the
publication in this case person just
tanked thanks it's text in the net and
immediately gut reaction of the audience
it could be 5 10 3 brother positive
reactions sometimes fraction might be
very rude or seen I don't know but it's
very easy way to be in touch with people
and if not if the talk and not about
team everyone who could do it besides
those people there are some really
significant more poets if we talk about
Russian poet it is max s turtle called
the name of Alex eats witkoff who lives
in Washington in fact but is your son
ski poets of next generation stanislav
of killing or garlic further swarovski
and many many others i have my thermic
oh and it is as i thought these is the
way to keep your fingers on pulse of
today's literature process salon are not
literature whole not literature so on
it's rather tree home if you remember
this novel or Russian story dubrovsky
dubrovsky had a contact with moshing car
through a tree hole where he left piece
of paper with everything here I wanted
to say in a sense livejournal is a tree
hole but with the other hand it's
possibility to contact almost like an
chart so if you think it it's alone I
don't mind
you